du haut de ces deux mètres à 53 ans John
phénomen espère devenir le futur
sénateur démocrate de la Pennsylvanie
natif de la région le lieutenant
gouverneur devance de peu son rival
républicain
c'est partisans sont en yes l'ambiance
est électrique
mais sa campagne Madeleine car ses
problèmes de santé font sans cesse la
une d'emblée il aborde le sujet
[Applaudissements]
parlons de l'éléphant dans la pièce
dit-il j'ai récemment eu un AVC
les seuls problèmes que j'ai sont
auditifs assurentides à ces partisans
parfois j'oublie un mot dit-il
deux mots qui n'existent pas
rien pour apaiser le camp démocrate des
gens inquiets
remontée dès qu'il a reçu le soutien de
Donald Trump
santé de son adversaire
où il est trop malade pour participer à
un débat
lundi matin 8h ce chirurgien est
personnalité un public fait campagne
dans un restaurant fermé en banlieue de
pittsburgers
il a le verbe facile et à 62 ans il
tente de ravir le vote des indécis
des dépenser dit ce partisan
républicains
c'est difficile pour une famille moyenne
de maître de la nourriture sur la table
dit-elle
l'augmentation du coût de la vie
inquiète et Dr hosse comme on l'appelle
ici la bien compris
sur Tik Tok le chirurgien fait ses
courses et s'insurge contre la flambée
des prix
20 dollars pour des crudités dit-il
pour les démocrates c'est l'élection de
la dernière chance pour sauver la
démocratie rien de moi
la démocratie est en état de siège
dit-elle
selon le Washington Post 291 candidats
républicains aux élections de mi-mandat
ne reconnaissent toujours pas les
élections de 2020
il est possible qu'on ne puisse plus
avoir d'élections libres aux États-Unis
dit-il
notre démocratie est en train de faillir
dit-elle il y a la démocratie et puis le
droit à l'avortement qui est en jeu
personne ne peut me dire quoi faire avec
mon corps dit-elle
je défendrai toujours le droit à
l'avortement des John phalemen mais la
question n'est même pas abordée dans le
camp républicain
la vie commence dès la conception DJ
tout bonnement ici je crois à la pilule
miracle du doctorose après l'inflation
il va régler les problèmes de la
criminalité et de la drogue nous dit-on
comment on ne le sait pas mais il
convaincent
combien d'entre vous ont peur de marcher
la nuit dit-il ça n'arrivait pas il y a
deux trois ans
nombre de dents notre chambre plane
toujours sur cette campagne
doctorose va combattre la criminalité
dit-il va poursuivre tous les revendeurs
de drogue il faut sauver l'Amérique
la bataille est serrée une fois de plus
le pays est polarisé sur des questions
fondamentales
les deux parties veulent sauver
l'Amérique mais pas de la même façon
[Musique]
voyageables les élections du mandat sont
toujours très durs pour le président au
pouvoir et le Conseil actuel avec la
hausse du coût de la vie ça complique
les choses là pour Joe Biden
absolument vous savez ces élections de
mi-mandat c'est un peu un référendum sur
la présidence de Joe Biden alors
évidemment l'inflation on parle du coût
de la vie qui a augmenté de plus de 8%
c'est le loyer c'est la nourriture et ce
que Joe Biden espère c'est que les
Américains vont voter sur la question de
l'avortement et il espère que le vote
démocrate va sortir parce que vous savez
Céline la majorité des Américains sont
pour le droit à l'avortement et il
affirme que si les démocrates remportent
les deux chambres il va légiférer
là-dessus le défi c'est de sortir le
vote démocrate ouais mais ce qu'il y a
de très inquiétant et vous en parler
dans votre reportage c'est que dans 48
des 50 États il y a des candidats
républicains qui ne reconnaissent même
pas la victoire de Joe Biden à
l'élection de 2018
de 2020
à la chambre mais aussi des gouverneurs
des secrétaires d'État et c'est
postes-là ce sont des postes clés quand
il y a des élections présidentielles ce
sont les personnes qui vont compter les
votes et quand il va avoir un vote très
serré c'est eux qui vont trancher je
vous donne juste l'exemple de l'Arizona
par exemple la candidate républicaine au
poste de gouverneur Kerry Lake ne
reconnaît pas les résultats des
élections de 2020 le secrétaire d'État
le candidat républicain lui est un os
qui peuvent CV il fait partie de ces
groupes qui ont tenté de de prendre
d'assaut le Capitole ce sont deux
candidats si les résultats sont très
serrés ils pourraient trancher du côté
républicain et c'est ce qui inquiète
beaucoup les démocrates donc on va
suivre ces élections mimandat avec vous
merci à Z
je vous en prie